помідор
селям алейкум дорогі телеглядачі
сьогодні як завжди ввечері в середу в
ефірі від r програма кримське питання
сьогодні у нас у гостях міністр
освіти науки України
пані лілія гриневич доброго обчислимо
алейкум а ви ще не знає жодних слів
по кримськотатарському трунарю я поважаю
6 град хорош а тіль для самого квіти і
я навіть рада бутово
у вас ефірі я знаю що травку відразу
погодилися прийти і ви нещодавно міністр
і одна з тем, які ви займаєтеся
самого початку це зокрема тема
кримських хлопців студентів які мають
зараз ось компанія починається
вступна я багато читав всяких
інформаційних повідомлень але не
розрізнені то прийняли це.
по-друге я то журналіст але наші глядачі
у криму вони не зобов'язані все читати
тому той чудовий момент коли люди
можуть почути з перших вуст з вуст
міністра поетапно що зроблено і що
зараз яка зараз ситуація з кримськими
випускниками шкіл представься я хочу
сказати ще я та тварюка dooper ікона наш
дублету щоб ми їм лоррейн тигра вати
крим в україну українці
часті на україни нам потрібно зрубали
так щоб гіти в криму малий шанс зранку
цю українську свиту причому у хорошу
українського кольору з мистецтв для бору
широти для них доступ досьє та українською
розвинені dota промінь у кримчан та малих
ступа ти фактично за результатом через
зовнішнього вигляду задач на ваті його не я ми
не могли підтвердити і
свої знання та примати атестат з
позику середнього світу навчаєтеся
екстерном в українських школах есенція
була приголомшена
алла ми заткнулася про судно нею пари
повну ж саме
дудакова сесії як було передачі на
довгих накладалася вона складу не еге
російських і зрозуміло, що це дуже
важко було об'єднати випускникам і ми
пішли на зустріч запиту мустафи
джемілева народного депутата для того
щоб організувати для кримчан
додаткову сесію
яка буде вже після здачі останнього
іспиту еге
тобто якщо хтось не встиг щось
знати він повинен звернутися зараз до
нашим центром оцінювання та вся
інформація є на сайті міністерства
освіти та науки та зареєструватися
на додаткову сесію це спеціальна
сесія яка створена саме для
кримчан
вона відбуватиметься 2 по 9 червня та on
any new
липня врятуй великий коли 2 по 9 липня
саме в цей час вони зможуть здавати
зовнішнє незалежне оцінювання в Україні
але зареєструватися треба до 28 червня
є сказати про те, що хочеш та що ти
там не встиг приїхати, але ти приїдеш на
додаткову сесію, але є ще одна
можливість яку ми передбачили
ще коли я очолювала комітет з
питанням освіти науки верховному
раді України верховній раді тоді ми
внесли закон саме який заповнює
право кримчан у такій складній ситуації
коли діти вже де-факто навчаються два
року в російській йшло іншій програмі
за зовсім іншою програмою вони не
вивчають
ось це і сіллю України
історію України розкрився до української
літератури і звичайно ж вони не рівні
умовах
в порівнянні з нашими українськими
випускних випускниками з підготовки до
зовнішньому незалежним від це досить
серйозне оцінювання але
досить жорстка дуже багато питань
і тоді пояснимо гвинтівки і на шлюб і
тому ми вперше передбачили ще
одну можливість вступати за
вступним іспитам гризунів без
зовнішньої та без н.л.
але при цьому це буде обмежена кількість
наших університетів ми думаємо що це
буде 10 університетів вже на
наступного тижня буде надано
список цих університетів це
університети в різних містах України
це університети, які будуть покривати
весь спектр спеціальностей і за цих
університетах працюватимуть центри
які ми називаємо освітні
центри крим україна
що роблять ці центри дуже плюс
по-перше ви приїжджаєте до такого центру та
у цей центр можете подати свою
освітню декларацію у відомості
декларації оскільки ми не можемо
приймати на підставі російських
атестатів і для нас треба ось здати все
ж цей український компонент
українською мовою та українською по
історії України оскільки ви повинні все
ж довести що ви можете навчатися на
українською мовою в українській
університеті і ви здаєте ось подаєте
декларацію з вашими гілками
звідти звідти і в атестаті ми
напишемо за цими відмітками просто
атестований треба буде здати і компонент
українська мова історія України там же
цьому освітньому центрі та крім того
треба скласти вступний іспит у
залежно від спеціальності на яку
лікар призначить етапі там хімії та біології
якщо на інші спеціальності
це все буде оголошено на цих сайтах
університетах вони скажуть по яких
спеціальностям які будуть вступні
іспити
що дуже важливо якщо ви захочете потім
підтвердити саме українську від
атестат з усіма оцінками
ви зможете протягом року спокійно здати
всі монети немає це не за нього це просто
державна атестація у вигляді
іспиту шкільного та отримати ще
повноцінний український атестат є ще
одна річ, яку ми передбачили ми
розуміємо що багато абітурієнтів не
зможуть приїхати з українським паспортом
та це ж горілка людей паспорт отримали
навіть не мільйон звучить тому ми
запрошуємо і без українського паспорта
треба мати свідчення
виродження і якщо це не впав на літні
ще абітурієнт потрібний та їм немає 18 років
його заява про вступ має бути
завірено кимось із батьків та
іншою людиною який художника де
завірено російський нотаріат
ви ж кримський нотаріус
визнаєте я думаю що це воно
повинно бути завірено все ж таки тут у
україні хороше питання це деталі та хочу
вам сказати що юридичні аспекти цих
всіх питань вони будуть виписані на
сайті міністерства освіти ми робимо
спеціальну таку дорожню карту
за простою схемою показала яким чином
рухатися що ви маєте передбачити
крок за кроком та ось така дорожня карта
ось цим коло і для відриву українську
від та статутів ступу до вищих початкових
закладів вона вже є на сайті
міністерства але вона поки що передбачає
тільки вступ через лише зовнішнє
незалежне тестування, тобто за нього
а ось буде ще одна доповнена буквально
я думаю до кінця цього тижня і там буде
вже ось цей новий механізм прописано
через вступні іспити я хочу до
глядачам звернутися на сказати що
по-перше заходьте на сайт ну всі люди
грамотно та вчити користуватися інтернетом
напевно вже нікого не треба ще
на екрані у нашому бачите телефони
гарячої лінії міністерство освіти
науки херсонського центру теж які
цим займаються також ось на сайті
видимі але це в новинах буде але на
на сайті ви всі викладете список десяти
вузів ось цих які будуть за особливою
програмі приймати навіть без паспортів
українських і без сну і там вся ця
технологія є і буде описано вірніше я
буду вважати що ви трохи запізнився
все ж таки я можемо ігровим його такі
ти так мами тя треба було рубай також і
минуло в уроку ну ось залишився часу то
ось доїдають ще закон ми написав з
почну раніше авіація велика бюрократична
esp одна машина там вчитися та закон
трава була провести їх ось це через
парламент і я рада шуму не вдалося
труби ти від atari активка я стала
міністром я відразу купа лацій законної
буквально того дня коли президент його
підписав пудра зуші реалізовуватися вид
по видно в умовах прийому і всім ірою що
той м'яз у мережі е
документи та типу vázі з супом їжу ж
серйозним і
і ви не проходите місяця скупого джей я
рада що нам вдалося нації шлях пройти і
ми сюди дати кого дорогу для випускних і
воскр йому в доступі до українського світла і
про клади тобто фактично ви готували
цей закон так за якими ви зараз
працювати але рубін і від за раз реалізуємо
і добрий рахунок
адже цим вузли ми не можемо за раз про
називати з кількох у нас буде
випускники можна його тілу руку та їх куди
менше через те, що так пизду
ми кут охолонув і крутив адже можна овець і
будуть у стоять таки паршивості скай і ми
всі цілі механізм буду проти ти буду
мого дали продовжу в цій а при когось
і доступному руку тому що де тайяки
будуть випускникам і наступна урока ми не
знаємо що наступна ерік нам matuya ми
все відсік йому повернення криму
то чоловіків незаконної анексії криму в
принципі по рушниці та весь міжнародний
порядок і розуміти все
праведник раїни свиту частоту акція
хто до болячка на залікували міжнародного
права та гаряча черв'яного гаряча точка
була приватних порушити у сфері
міжнародного права і не слухають і
нацистських і нам до витримки
but i у загибньому та справедливі ситуації
ми миємо адати чоловіки весь кримчанам з
дубу ти
розквітнуть якщо говорити про те що
україна для україни крим це україна для
світової спільноти крим це україна
але
тоді напевно логічно щоб
українське будь-яка структура будь-яке
міністерства та провести ставилася
кримчанам як де-факто зараз мешканцям
україни треба щоб давала їм усе
можливості або освіти так само і
вимерли утворити ну ось щодо
освіта просто впевнена, бо
це молоді люди у яких якраз
формується їх світогляд
так званий знає і
і але зараз йому ж насаджує цей
російська
навчання в російській школі з різними
зовсім витягти збоченими фактами
історії з цієї з цим потоком брехні
звичайно нам треба виривати звідти дітей та
давати можливість ну принаймні
тим хто хоче обов'язково мати
можливість здобути освіту більше
того я хочу підкреслити, що ми
передбачаємо квоти квоти для кримчан
тобто якщо вони доведуть, що вони
проходять ось цей бар'єр на
вступних іспитах вони повинні
довести що вони ви якщо але це були він
невисокий це невисокий бар'єр але
звичайно за кожною спеціальністю ви
повинні мати якийсь базовий рівень
підготовки але якщо вони доводять це
базовий рівень підготовки ми
передбачаємо для них бюджетне місце
навчання і вони зможуть навчатися за
гроші
української держави і це про це
був саме закон адже ситуація якого
вони зараз do your та громадяни російської
федерації
але не визнаємо вже це громадян потрібно не
визнаємо звичайно це нав'язані
громадянства та
саме цей закон це відповідь, що ми
сприймаємо їх як громадян України та
будемо для них треба давайте безкоштовне
навчання як і громадянам України це
дуже важлива річ тому що але дивіться
є материнство на запитання та
країна питання пов'язані з надходженням
ось так якщо почати розбиратися я просто
знаю ситуацію там людину школяр
який їде сюди вчитися в Україні
насправді це міні герой там є
випадки коли доноси пишуть що він
збирається робити це фактично
банери з фашист це людина яка
їде просто вчитися тобто він уже
ризикує це що я сподіваюся всі ці
преференції працюватимуть це не
преференції там щоб інші які
українці нас дивляться що ось їм пільгові
якісь умови створюють і так далі
пірах не пільгове сказали все але все
здавати доведеться але крім накладені вони
не можуть заново здати тому що вони по
іншим програмам вчитися і так далі
є ніяких блату немає звичайно, а потім
ось у такій ситуації якою виявилися
там люди це справжній герой це людина
виїжджаючий що вчитися патріот україни 1
по-перше над по перше у друге
майбутній фахівець і так далі
далі вирваний вами з цієї російської
світу навчання в якому звичайно
ідеологічно страшно за шоріна та ви
має рацію і я абсолютно згодна що це
дуже важлива частина взагалі роботи для
україни зараз з тими людьми які
залишилися в криму і якщо ми не будемо
робити цю роботу потім можна тільки
себе звинувачувати і мені здається, що політика
держави яка була в попередні
роки була зовсім недостатньо
щодо криму як частини України і нам
потрібна ось ця інтеграція
ідентичностей коли ми різні але для нас
наша країна Україна і звичайно тут є
питання цінностей це дуже важливі
питання якраз майдан привернув увагу
до базової відмінності, наприклад, громадян
україни та
більшості я не говорю всіх але
більшості громадян Росії тобто і
напевно нас зараз багатьма людьми в
криму
об'єднують ось саме ця різниця в
цінностях
я говорю про тих громадян України
зараз живуть у криму не з власної волі
а з волі ось таких диких історичних
обставин та
що це коли людина не може жити
під пресингом тотального контролю
коли людина
калли калли люди направили свободи ви
людяна трава путчу владні видно sti та
поважаєш що нібито була владова на по
виношен уват і ланцюг обліку а владні
видно стей коли
люди на моє право на свободу думкою та
свободу слова та я стрибнув він вона що bates
кримчан я важкі в україні хай в україні
ми жив його найбіднішою і
нам дуже багато три бочки проти ти для
фарбування економічно фінансові
ситуації в Україні і я до того ж права
б ти
наших спин грому henriques знаходиться за
раз на алексі ваній території
а тут випробування що багата знаю ж
адже сьогодні бажають що таке пресинг
тоталітарну державну здійсню за два
року випадково їх шум і dvb-t черепахи
повернеш і new до кримських татар яки
абсолютно у вир wikivid буваєте на
території криму і за раз ми пройдемо
u2 митого тата дати чоловіка звістка син
дітям молодому поколінню ви їх від
крим тому що чоловіки весь навчання
в українець і для них також можна ж ви
їх від і тому що ми розуміємо що на
знімають на матеріальному жил і весь
важливо вашу вати проїхати менше місця
для студента для молоді ебана біси
мобільно і ось ту муцій важливо його самий
на тему етапі їх не класти a-data їм
такий шанс
але про інше та тациту перевірку я вже вам
говорила на початку ми б ви жодного разу
метаючи climb шину ми будемо ренд гру вати
крим і всі владні буди політики в
сенсеєм втягування молозі бо
самий team молодь я до тунця року біля свиту
і буду основним промо туром такий рейд
грати зрозуміло але ви кажете правду
500 та освіти жити де люди будуть
ось приїде один хлопець звідти
одна дівчина їздить поселити у river city
то спробу що він і без кущів на і
навчання
в одному включаючи випадково стипендію та нам
треба буде ви вирішите що харчування гурту
рідким та проживання я думаю що ти
харчування можна буду ви вирішите все
адже закласти кіль кістки кримчан які
приїдуть на вони танцювали ви знаєте нам
теж складний їх провести турнір хоче
сказати лише уб'ють на сайті ж можна
записувати у нас navitel уде акіри і
струменів води будуть реєстр уват якщо ми
побачимо вщух то й засмутиться цеху світло
них центрів у нас на приклад
реєстрації на сонячне за навіть на
ватине вання та он і складу it's овочі
на складного тіні ми не можемо
ідентифік уват та всіх кримчан
а чому ж просте причин це гусак цих
то перебудуватися на зоні овен з
знаходиться вона на вч вони екстернат а кліп
на ній до української школи того українця
вчитися в днр ми вирішили не в магате
відомих цру побут ми
цикли такі на пружині консультації
алла і зрозуміло ці репресії та роботу
різьблений монетних спецслужб які хочеш
пройду сити придушить its обожнення їх від
і в Україні ми розуміємо будь-яку врахування
інформація кому ж будь єдиний і будь
виявлено що візуалізовано про
люди ніс криму я як хочеш виїхати на
тапчани в Україні може чому ти ви
карстона для того, щоб не дати їм
потрібний вигляд звичайно тим більше
розумієте
армія військкомати
російська влада не церемонитися не з
ким кримські татари взагалі не хочуть там
ніде служити вони хочуть їхати вчитися
а як буде але скажемо так ви не фахівець
безпеки як ось мінімізувати
ось ці ризики щоб на етапі надходження
хоча б не знали що відбувається з
конфіденційної інформації ми нікуди не
доїду ми її не заплутував і плюс про
зовнішньому буде заданому оцінювання
і новачкові і ми думали за розставляти
харчування журналісти з кількою і я говорю ми
не знаємо у ми ми не знаємо з праги не
знаємо з кількома і я не можу
каченя це за раз масштабі завись custom
щось та датського сесія
вкладено тпр так пузо нього і тепер я що
і але на жаль найкращу можна за вступаємо і
випробувані давайте ми дам йому жилося про
клас ти всю дорогу ти хто скластися і
роки їхнього від та maniacs цифри ми не
заявляємо уа інформації застудники-віки
подадуться до своїх середніх центрів
крим україна на базі ти з цією в
університеті в будокан сидіть на це
важливо насправді для всіх, хто зараз
думає звичайно потрібно їхати вчитися в
україну тому що україни від вікна
Європу це вікно до іншої освіти
тут обмін і але просто я наведу приклад
що тут майже кожен вуз
нормальний він має зв'язки з Європою
програм tempus риза монетних еразмус
плюс україна за раз вийшло а якщо
асоціації з європейським союзом до бага
тих європейських проектів пов'язані з
вищу святу у нас я так уже
університетські програми з подвійних
дипломів lfp шутер ось риба входить і
на обидві яну спеціальність на бакалавра та
далі потреби можна роздавити якщо у
трасу скажу що ті 10 університеті я
ким ми включаємо всю програму c
університету я типу перше беруть на себе
зменшу звук у важливо намагайтеся від у
кримчан ось на нижній базі будуть в
відкриття не центри
україна крим далі c
університети акимович хороша кисть
усвяти
топтація на університети д у нас є
розум не на якісь його світи тому що
самі це важливий випуск мені не аби які
там так ми прибираю 410 університеті
викликалася на тому, що у ставити не
програми з їхнього університету кс правді
хороший цеху гаю розуму ви почали їх
кричить не версте ти
хотілося б торкнутися питання про
університеті тону таврійського
національність це не вернадського
яка університет біженець
це єдина територія Європи
університет біженців і біженець я знайомий
добре та й ви знайомі з володимиром
казарин ректором які
але він взагалі такий світило області
філології дуже шанована людина він
переїхав до Києва
як ми знаємо він зібрав команду з
викладачів і вони фактично я знаю
ви їм допомагали ще коли ми були у
верховній раді
фактично створена волонтерських засадах
такий університет відроджений тут
час поки що крим не знаходиться до або
факту складі україна зараз я просто
ним розмовляв та гаррі що ми готові
вже повністю готова до всього
проблема одна є взагалі немає жодної копійки
грошей університету досі 11 липня
настає вже компанії вступна
якось мені здається треба цю проблему
вирішити тому що це єдиний виш
почну україна
вибачте утримувала всі вузи всі навчальні
заклади в криму а зараз на єдності та
us який відроджується тут у Києві
чомусь немає грошей як так вийшло
так зараз на проблемою моє забарвлення
розбавляла сьогодні всього приводу з
вадимом у кращому чернишів міністру 100
нових територій так і вини в
інтерактивний процес всі ми на плівку та
закриваючи волохат дискусія з міністром
фінансів тому що нас правді в табриз до
університету я каштан арагон алан тик вже
на заморозенні прийшли за вишки кішки
не раз за раз та та їй це це
якісно харчуванням та з вини здобута
розпакувати не з їхньої кішки
мети вежі проблеми взаємовигідний
захльостає кримом так і ванну і
територію
довідки складно тому що в бюджеті 2016
руку не було перед баштового для
університету Пушкін і за раз перед
батчат і таку нову бюджетну програму
практично він йому живіт а версію дном і
мама знає і шлях і
при наймі на фінансування спочатку
початкового руку і блок душа добрий їм
це жах подіємо з ще нам би здалася
і щоб англійський університет так уже був
одним вірш університеті які може
примати кримчан розбивається
політичного житлові вали для чого там по
ви не начебто видно у світлодарську
склад ми моєму адже критий там тесту
часті але саме набору наки
спеціальності давно вже сильний склад
крима гуманітарні спеціальності
там вже й одразу мило що такі факультети
які зажадають владика володіння і
лабораторні бази потрібні ось так шви
кущ валить але як це ну звичайно це на
порожньому місці не переїхала ж не
створенням низу лабораторіями там
перекуплю з мізками викладачі та zara
склав його щоб ви буду вали
у правильному руслі роботу університету
шов пишуть жертву за цими спеціальностями
і університет може тут немає і набери
абітурієнтів набери студентів та вчених ну
що нашим це штаб старшого вірусний
такий набив печатку на писанину мовчання
це улюблене його скачав я розумію що
нещодавно на посаді міністра але як би
зовсім у темі і але не може бути такого
що ось навчальний рік розпочався без
таврійському зупинилися і чайна вона я
зараз не готова вам сказати про якісь
доктор спеціальностей може нібито
цьому університеті старшого верес
зрозуміло, це вже деталі не буде 20 і
вирішуєте вас є програма є
вимога до університету і так далі
те, що люди самі створили універ
надзвичайно мета кодових абсолютно з
можна класів і кувата її капот допоможіть
людям здійснити подвиг до кінця
будь ласка місяця чорнець він миття трояндами
відомий і на стіни з міністром фінансів
нові карти на місяць зберіть з цього
питання будь ласка тому що це важливо
просто я скажу так але гіпотетично
можна напевно без будь-якого вишу боїтеся
але це такий дуже важливий знак для цієї
розуміємо вчаться з правді дуже важливо
сигнал політичний з 1, а подруга я хочу
сказати те що там де брався готовий
колектив на йому вірних людей до
і таких людей потреби нувот її за
розпаковані всі роблять вища на
владних на владному ентузіазмі і ми
нецид вже більше що при круговороті я до
міністру лапок і що
абзацу та коротку годину скелі новий ряд
харчування фінансово не я не здавався ворогові
лева
ясно що будемо протитум цим напевно
багато справ але все-таки я вас прошу тому
що
крима та особлива територія ви сама
всю передачу розповідали про те, як
наскільки це важливий
цього б важливою справою я не вчився стану
але я знаю як належить кримчани і
кримські татари та будь-які інші кримчани
відноситься і до того як своїм альма-матер
які закінчуємо протягом там 20 до
багатьох років і це грошей не порожній звук
також коли їх не порожній звук не
професора казарин і я впевнений, що якщо
не обов'язково все-таки я вважаю
провести україна йде який раніше
фінансувати весь крим знайде на один
університет для його старту гроші та
пройде кампанія вступна
і все-таки це буде вітрина така
яку в тому числі мені здається в тому
Число може бути одне з головних що
покаже жити їм крим особливо молодим
шлях справжні справжні українці в
сьогодення в нову Україну та в нову
Європу ви ж
європейський міністр освіти душі сп
одягайся при наймі ми правильним шляхом
ми
ви спочатку сік у мого вже стилям і куди
знайди мій околиця її за це заплачено
дуже багато бельських жике
починаючи стеки були на майдані та
техніки продовжуються раз u20 великому
адже столики в центрі Європи до вати і
а кезана заручниць країни павутиння над то
дорога і я думаю що їх що тоді прошу
червоне про українську та проєвропейську
міністр тобі нічого роботи над і кусати
то я віддаю рексу ж яйця частка і випав
короткий проміжок взуті у ряді це ми
будемо ми всі раби ти сам для того
щоб наші гіти та кримські гіти та наші
маги темряви мало можна весь ранок, а ти
добрий і про почет в Україні кращого то
себе повноцінними європейцями
одегова з нами було міністр освіти
та науки україни лілія гриневич
до зустрічі наступної середи ввечері
дякую велике ви зрозуміли все одно
ru